my experience for the Derby going in I
didn't practice for it either because I
got hot right before the break so I
didn't practice at all until 10 minutes
before the Derby I went in the cage and
I just tried to start hitting homers
third swing in I knew this ain't it I
got no chance how was your BP guy he
practiced for at least two weeks so he
was locked in I threw him off because I
didn't hit any home runs and he's like
okay where do I throw it because he's
not hitting the home runs in my head I'm
like just throw it I'm not hitting home
runs it was a great experience but
unless my son really really really
really really really wants me to later
on in my career I will never never again
never do it again what I'm supposed to
do when Julio goes for 40. when bloody
put up 26 or 26 or 27 I was like oh my
gosh yeah there's no way I can do it
yeah and so and the basements can be
used and everything is still their juice
for everybody yeah they're not just
juice for me yeah